Our Rural Area & Small Settlements
Ō Tātou Hapori Taiwhenua me nga Nohoanga
Rural areas currently make up the majority
of the District, and agriculture and the rural
economy play a major part in the District’s
wealth creation, employment and character.
The Waimakariri District has one of the largest
lifestyle-block populations
of any district in the country.
We need to be mindful that further lifestyle
development may impact on large-scale productive
land use and the character of the rural area.
The District also features small rural towns
and settlements.
These are diverse in both location and character
and we need to think carefully about what
we want them to look like in the future.
Our District Our Future, Waimakariri 2048
aims to:
So what do you think?
Let us know your thoughts and find out more
about the District Development Strategy at
waimakariri.govt.nz